twenty-eight years ago a small group of
forward-looking dentists in New York
City feeling that certain disputed
questions in dental pathology demanded
investigation by men trained in science
who were apparently not available in the
dental profession conceived the idea of
interesting a biological chemist in
dental research they took up the matter
with the head of the department of
biological chemistry at Columbia
University little dreaming how far the
byproducts of that relationship would
outgrow their original purpose but the
young man they interested in dental
research was a human dynamo who had much
more color in his hair then and now
his name was William J dies a man then
unknown in dentistry now synonymous with
dental research and dental progress in
many fields July 11th 1937 the leaders
of the dental profession came together
from all parts of the United States and
Canada under the auspices of the
American College of dentists the
American Dental Association the Canadian
Dental Association the American
Association of dental schools the
National Association of Dental Examiners
the American Association of dental
editors the dental section of the
American Association for the Advancement
of science the International Association
for dental research and the Omicron
Kappa Upsilon Society to pay homage to
an outstanding benefactor of Dentistry
in this videotape we will see why
William Jay guys was the most
influential person to the development of
Dentistry in the 20th century in the
United States and Canada
1900 America was seeing vast changes in
transportation communications and in
health care
however dentistry had made little
progress since its birth in the 1840s
dentists were still not considered part
of the health care team and had not yet
organized into a profession mechanics
not medicine was the basis for dental
education and one young professor was
inspired to crusade for a better way dr.
William John guys was born February 21st
1872 in Reisterstown Baltimore County
Maryland shortly after the death of his
father in 1874 he returned with his
mother to her parents home in Mannheim
Pennsylvania where he resided during his
boyhood he was graduated from the
Manheim High School in 1888 and from
Gettysburg College in 1893 at Gettysburg
he edited the college monthly and the
junior annual and captained the baseball
team during his junior and senior years
guys attended Yale from 1893 to 1897
where he received the degree of Doctor
of Philosophy he was appointed to the
medical teaching staff of Columbia
University in 1898 passing through the
usual grades of promotion from
instructor to the chair of full
professor in 1905 here he founded the
first department of biological chemistry
in a medical school while at Columbia
he married Mabel L lark of Millersburg
Pennsylvania in the spring of 1909 guys
was approached by two prominent New York
dentists doctors Howe and Merritt who
recruited him to do research on the
prevention of dental caries guys quickly
found there was little research that was
being done in this area and there was a
prevailing indifference to dentistry and
scientific educational and medical
circles what were the reasons for this
prevailing indifference to dentistry
dentistry was generally regarded more as
trade than a profession it was
provincial in its tendencies and
relationships and did not encourage its
practitioners to participate actively in
public affairs its science
chiefly that of prosthetic mechanics had
exerted little influence beyond the
useful applications its growth in
professional quality had been greatly
retarded by a system of journalism that
was predominantly non-professional under
editorial leadership that was commercial
and selfish and its educational system
was mainly proprietary chiefly
technological and biologically weak as
guys began his investigation into dental
research he realized a trend in medical
education that deeply disturbed him in
his own words became conscience most
physicians been ignoring dental
conditions but also in the medical
schools the teachers of the so-called
Medical Sciences myself among them had
been overlooking or disregarding the
teeth this strikingly negative situation
with its prejudices and in justices
clearly represented a serious public
detriment from the day of that
realization to this I have had an
increasing purpose in serving the public
welfare to promote the advancement of
Dentistry during the next decade guys
enthusiastically undertook the
biomedical research projects proposed by
the doctors Howe and merit and launched
a movement that would change the face of
Dentistry forever guys already a
successful researcher was profoundly
aware of the lack of scientific
information in the dental field and in
1919 founded the Journal of dental
research just one year later his call
for an army of scientists from around
the world to investigate the cause of
dental disease provided the impetus for
the formation of the International
Association for dental research William
guys was also a shaping force in dental
education and forged a philosophy that
would become the core
stone of the medically based dental
curriculum one that did not simply turn
out tradesman but a non-proprietary
school validated by a recognized
institution of higher learning and so in
1916 in response to guys progressive
ideas the school of dental and oral
surgery was organized at Columbia
University the publication of the
Carnegie Commission of the guys report
in 1926 was perhaps guys most
outstanding contribution his conclusions
had a profound impact on dental
education he called for higher
pre-professional standards more and
better basic science instruction greater
correlation between clinical medicine
and dentistry more opportunities for
structured training in the specialties
and a greater commitment for ongoing
research guys continued to serve as
professor of biochemistry at columbia
editor of the journal of dental research
general secretary of the international
association for dental research and was
a member of many other scientific
organizations during his career he
published over 600 papers
pamphlets and books since 1950 the
William Jay guys Foundation for the
Advancement of Dentistry created to
carry out guys ideals has given its
support and funding for scholarly
journalism and research in dentistry
current projects and awards of the
foundation include support for the
Journal of dental research support for
the dental teacher training fellowship
program of the American Fund for dental
health the guys award in editorial
writing the guys award for research in
periodontics the guys award for research
in oral and maxillofacial surgery the
guys award for Latin American dental
research scholarships for students at
Columbia and Marquette University's a
biography William J guides his
contribution to the advancement of
Dentistry by dr. Frank Orland
1993 for further information please
contact the William Jay guys foundation
for the advancement of Dentistry 839
quince orchard boulevard suite J
Gaithersburg Maryland two zero eight
seven eight one six zero three three
zero one nine seven seven three two two
three